[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
give me one minute and I'll show you how
Cloud run simplifies running
containerized workloads
Cloud run provides fully managed compute
to run containers abstracting away all
infrastructure management
whether you own event-driven
long-running services or deploying
containerized jobs to process data Cloud
run automatically scales your containers
up and down from zero this means you
only pay when your code is running
you can write code using your favorite
language framework and libraries package
this up as a container run gcloud run
deploy and your app will be live
provided with everything it needs to run
in production
Cloud run can also automate how you get
to production using build packs to
enable you to deploy directly from
source
Services get a secure endpoint with TLS
termination on your custom domain while
jobs allow you to perform batch
processing with each instance running in
parallel and if you ever need to run
outside of cloud run Cloud run workloads
are portable thanks to Cloud run using
and API compatible with kubernetes
so the next time you're wondering where
to run your containerized workload keep
Cloud run in mind
[Music]